My name is Alex Hormozi. I'm an
entrepreneur and investor.
And today, I own a portfolio of
companies that generates over [music]
$250 million
in aggregate revenue each year. But, it
didn't start out like this. 15 years
ago, I was sleeping on the floor of my
gym trying to make my first business
work.
>> Hey guys, Alex here. Welcome back.
>> Because of that journey, I founded
acquisition.com. Where my team and I
help other entrepreneurs get through the
hard, lonely parts of starting and
scaling a business.
>> [laughter]
>> To show you what happens behind the
scenes, I brought eight business owners
together to compete for $100,000
and this golden ticket, which gives them
access to an entire year of guidance
from myself and the team behind my $250
million per year portfolio.
Each business owner has 60 minutes with
me to explain their business. So, tell
me about the business.
>> I own Keith's Roofing Company.
>> Founder of Boulder Adventure Park.
>> I help people make stickers.
>> And at the end, I'll give them a road
map to scale their business as much as
they can in 90 days. What do you think
stopping you right now? You're thinking
about this.
>> I am.
>> I'm thinking about this. Biggest thing
that I don't like about the business is
I hate selling hourly with a vicious
passion. All right, let's see where
you're at in the scaling road map. This
is my big 20X lever.
>> When we'll be talking hundreds.
>> We have to. You're losing a price
because they have nothing else to say.
>> The second wild idea that I had and
again, this is wild.
>> It's like
>> Some will scale.
>> This is awesome.
>> Some will fail.
Only one will win the grand prize.
The question is,
do I want to spend a year working with
you to scale this?
So, the verdict is,
this is Scale or Fail.